le dossier ukrainien au coeur de
l'actualité les occidentaux accusent la
russie de vouloir envahir l'ukraine ce
que moscou dément le kremlin devant lui
la fin de l'extension de l'otan à l'est
et des garanties pour sa sécurité
mais les négociations semblent piétiner
emmanuel macron qui s'est entretenu à ce
sujet plusieurs fois par téléphone avec
un vladimir poutine sera en russie lundi
en contre face à face entre les deux
présidents les précisions depuis moscou
dans notre cause pendante darragh of man
après trois entretiens par téléphone une
rencontre en bonne et due forme le
kremlin confirmés et les pourparlers à
moscou le 7 février on trouve la demeure
poutine emmanuel macron ces négociations
prévue lundi à la mi-journée au kremlin
seront suivis d'une conférence de presse
selon dmitri peskov porte-parole du
président russe et sera question des
garanties de sécurité mutuelle entre la
russie et le temps la dîmière poutine
compte expliquer la position et les
préoccupations russes la question de la
non expansion de l'otan vers l'est sujet
essentiel pour la russie a été notamment
soutenue par le leader chinois dans une
déclaration commune publiée ce vendredi
4 février dmitri peskov a également
réagi aux déclarations du département
d'état américain sur la préparation par
mouscou de fausses vidéos visant
justifier une offensive russe en ukraine
je vous propose d'écouter je recommande
de ne pas croire qui que ce soit sur
parole sur tout le département d'état
américain quand il s'agit de telles
questions plus tôt dans la journée c'est
le chef de la diplomatie russe sergueï
lavrov qui avait qualifié de déni à les
déclarations du département d'état
américain écoutez j'ai vu j'ai regardé
sur internet des déclarations du
département d'état selon lesquelles la
russie préparait une fausse vidéo
montrant une attaque de militaires
ukrainien contre le dombass ce genre
d'histoire sont de plus en plus
nombreuses chaque jour et sont un délire
évidente pour n'importe quel politologue
ayant de l'expérience
selon le kremlin le président russe doit
rencontrer le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz qui viendra à son tour à moscou
le 15 février le kremlin n'exclut pas
non plus une rencontre avec le président
ukrainien wladimir zelensky